this is so annoying that I even have to
do this next segment but I want to just
do it and get it on the record so that
every time people ask me did you see
what sam cedar or ana kasparian or
whoever said about you David we can
hopefully short-circuit a lot of those
conversations it's become really trendy
for some of the progressive media
audience to go around effectively
tattletaling to other shows and getting
them to react to what other people are
saying and then playing that back off of
the original host or off of some other
person so I'll give you an example of
how this nonsense works I say something
someone calls in to Sam cedar and says
Sam did you did you see what David
Pakman said then they take Sam's
reaction of to something that by the way
Sam has not seen and then they go to
some third host and they say hey did you
see what sam cedar said about what David
Pakman said and then they call into my
show ten days later and they they say
David did you see what so-and-so said
about what so-and-so said about what you
said now 10 or 14 days ago but the real
problem is not the tattling like okay
it's fine there's this kind of
progressive media environment where a
lot of the hosts are in touch and we're
sort of sharing an audience to some
degree the problem is that people are
misquoting me endlessly and wasting
everybody's time and I'm gonna play an
example for you here okay I was on the
Joe Rogan program in Los Angeles last
week in that interview I said that the
left needs to be careful about defining
itself too narrowly and starting to
exclude ideas or people that are
reasonable ideas or reasonable people
and I gave the example of different ways
of getting health care for everybody and
I pointed out that expanding Medicare to
include everyone in a Medicare for All
system is one idea and it's a good idea
but that there are lots of other ideas
that I'm open to these all would be
systems of universal coverage
many are single-payer but my point was
it could look more like Canada it could
look more like the UK or France or
Germany although I don't think that the
Singapore system is exactly the best
path forward there are elements of the
Singapore system that are interest
but my point was all of these systems
are better than ours
let's not shut out good ideas or exclude
people who have other ways to get to
real Universal total health coverage for
anybody so a caller went to Sam cedar
completely miss stated my position as
being for a public option which is like
the softest most right-wing modification
we could make to the system we have an
ass Sam cedar to react to that which of
course is not what I actually said this
is a waste of time now of course Sam
said I don't know what David said but
more importantly now Sam is responding
to something I never actually said and
we all lose when this happens
we're fighting ideas that I didn't even
put forward let's take a look at it hey
Sam this is Nick from scout Nick what's
on your mind
alright just on the data stack thing Joe
Rogan's thing so David Pakman and
overall good comes here I don't like
those most I mostly agree with though
there were some pretty terrible takes on
Dell on Omar that I have trouble getting
over I mean let's actually stop there
just briefly there's another example my
terrible takes on ill on Omar where I
called her anti-semitic is typically the
way this goes which I never did I must
have said 25 times now I did not say L
on Omar is anti-semitic I did not say
that what Alon omar said is inherently
anti-semitic I said merely there are
many examples of this same historically
anti-semitic trope of Jewish conspiracy
to control and what Alon Omar said
referred to that period okay that that's
it I didn't say she was anti-semitic
I didn't say what she said his
anti-semitic period and yet endlessly
I'm having to respond to critiques for
things I didn't say but let's not go to
that one because we have a different one
that we're dealing with so let's get
back to the Sam cedar show but anyways
regardless with Joe Rogan he made a
concession that the left is too absolute
specifically on the topic of Medicare
for all I want to hear what you guys
think that this take seems like he's
open
the type plan Liz Warren has also been
flirting with as she all steps away from
medicare-for-all
on note you guys think of that
characterized that plan because I mean I
didn't I didn't what would what did
Backman say I think he's open he's open
to the public option things like that he
says that the less is too absolute about
wanting just Medicare for all he thinks
that there's other plans that we can go
with in regards solving the Medicare
issue I mean III I don't I'm not even
going to play Sam's response because I
didn't say what the caller wants Sam to
react to
I've not stepped away from Medicare for
all I haven't said that what I want is a
public option which is so lame I have
not said any of it what's the point in
getting Sam to react to something I
didn't say I've been at the forefront of
this issue on health care for a decade
for as long as I've been doing the show
there's no upside to the movement to
going to Sam cedar and getting him to
react to a position that is not mine
single-payer doesn't have to mean
Medicare for all when you look at all
the systems that are better than ours
whether it's Canada or the UK
Netherlands Switzerland Germany France
whatever they aren't all single-payer
many of them are but in all of them the
government plays a major role as both a
regulator and a funder through taxation
the private sector often still exists to
different degrees
some places you still have private
insurance as an option that's available
if you want it to different degrees
private industry is still running
hospitals or some clinics or whatever
everybody has to have coverage no matter
what system they have you need that to
have the largest possible risk pool you
could argue that the German system might
more easily build on what we have in a
more immediate way that would be a
respectable position the French system
is great but 90% of the population has
something beyond the national system is
what elements of that might make sense
in any case the point is we are wasting
time when we do this when I say a and a
caller goes to Sam and to Sam David
Pakman said be
react to it and sam says well based on B
I think C I never said B okay so C is
pointless it's a waste of time let's
stop doing it okay let's stop the
tattling let's actually work
productively here to improve our country
to improve the society around us and not
waste anybody's time with this nonsense
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman
show while you're there follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman lots of behind
the scenes pictures and memes and all
sorts of stuff from my trip to Los
Angeles last week during which I
appeared on the Joe Rogan program an
interview that now it's actually doing
really well it has surpassed a ton of
these MMA folks that Joe Rogan sometimes
interviews and even some of the
political folks and only the first five
days I think a 1.2 million views now for
the Maine Joe Rogan interview which was
two hours so make sure you watch it keep
sharing it keep refreshing because we
want to get those numbers up as high as
possible and more exciting announcements
by the way coming up very soon